foreign
cities a learned Professor learns how to
talk to germs
[Music]
thank you
all right thank you I thank you
[Music]
now watch all I have to do is to take my
magnifying glass put it over my machine
just like this and here you see
OTB himself
[Music]
tell me the story of your life
okay doc well to begin with my family
for Generations lived in the lungs of a
nice lady of course she didn't know she
had tuberculosis she thought it was
bronchitis
then one day some of my ancestors
managed to get into the lungs of her
favorite nephew little Peter
watch how neatly the job was done
[Music]
me in she goes
and so I tumbled into Peter's lung oh
boy it was pink and cozy
[Music]
thank you
then Presto you should see how my family
grew
come on Dan
but Peter was young and healthy his body
cell surrounded us at every angle and
just as we began to enjoy our new home
the cell holds completely surrounded us
they had us stopped
but after Peter grew up he neglected his
help he studied too hard
[Music]
he also played too violently
our first encouragement
Peter lost his appetite
then one day Ole Aunt Matilda came back
to town that kiss gave us three
enforcements we needed
the boom was on for us
[Music]
[Applause]
finally they took Peter to a sanatorium
the doctor said to rest
[Music]
oh in spite of everything we could do
Peter got well
[Music]
I tried desperately to escape and made
it so here I am one of the last
survivors say can't you help me to get
started again why I pledge to wipe out
you and all your kind and here's how
I'll do it
let me tell you about my little friend
Mary
first the doctor made a skin test a
tuberculin test
in two days a little red spot showed
that germs like you were in her body and
because you were there an x-ray picture
of the lungs was made
see here's the picture
[Music]
now there is a tubercle just like you
made in Peter and there some slight
changes to the lymph that is
tuberculosis in its earliest stage and
now Mary has a chance these medicines
will cure her rest and fresh air proper
diet
and good health habits
rest and fresh air
proper diet
[Music]
and good health habits
you have science on your side Professor
I see my finish
[Music]
hahaha